our pal hi Ron what's up buddy hey
you're live on the air they asked me to
be quiet okay I'm Hailie good man why
you lost a lot of weight you too thank
you dude
I'm okay shape I put some on recently
for a little role but how much have you
dropped I don't know oh yeah you know
you're not counting the pounds you just
kind of like hey I feel better I look
better I'm just gonna keep doing it you
know I get on the I get on the scales
from time to time and have it motivate
me I've just bought a bunch of new
clothes you did so I got to watch my
weight visits I'll throw a bunch of
clothes back in the trash I just went
through my entire wardrobe and either
took it to the tailor or gave it to
Goodwill yeah you gotta give
motivational [ __ ] right my new stuff
don't rid of that [ __ ] yep you're right
this way you can't grow back into it
that one day you're like I ate two
burgers last night you don't wanna put
on a medium instead of a small and
you're like oh [ __ ] just I saw Bob Kelly
yesterday on the street and he was
reminiscing about the leather jackets
that he used to be able to fit in so
when she was laying there getting a
medical [ __ ] truck tire in his face so
uh so you've lost weight what motivates
you to lose weight well I went through a
breakup and needed some [ __ ] I'm 60
nobody wants to [ __ ] a fat 60 year old
dude well you are Ron White I mean do
you find out like at first you go like
wow I'm famous so it shouldn't be a
problem then you're like oh no I'm fat
and famous this is a problem right well
that's what happened a Weinstein you
know at first he was just famous enough
to get these girls would would come bang
him and then I forgot where I was going
with this but but but then he was just a
fat guy and old and gross and that goes
away when I was 45 when I first started
getting to be a big comic or 50 seemed
like it was just thrown at me all the
time and you hit 60 that [ __ ] dries up
man because the audience gets older and
they get a little bit older and the ones
who loved you back then are now older
and married they say I don't want to
[ __ ] them anyway you don't not not my
old fans no yeah my you know my young
fans are coming on slowly but what's
your great like your age range when
you're trying to get laid
me you know I may be 42 40 50 something
like that okay I really don't I can't
stand listening young girl jabber
anymore and and and I have a girlfriend
so it's then she's a she's cool so you
broke up in June with your with the
woman you're with yes how long were you
together long time more than five years
yeah long enough that she claimed they
were married yes you didn't claim that
uh that's just probably I'm thinking
that's a monetary motivation or shedding
some light on that and and who broke up
with who was it you it wasn't her I you
know it was it was me but you know it's
just it can of run its course and so it
there didn't seem to be much in it for
me and you know she's a usually talented
person and she's quite capable of
getting out there and you know getting
after it like I do you know I still do
110 cities a year and I I really do you
know I don't mind working really hard if
but unless the other person is just
going on vacations without me and oh you
feel like if you're gonna put in the
effort make the money and they're gonna
go on vacations without you it's yeah
and but if if someone goes on vacations
without you were they going on vacations
where you weren't too sure what they
were doing it wasn't just without the
girlfriend
well I guarantee you're not completely
positive what but usually other
girlfriends I don't know you know I
don't know but it was more just like I'm
working and working and and the money
that I'm bringing in is just going right
out where I'm not even seeing it I'm
there's nothing literally yeah literally
suspicious mmm I get very suspicious
very fast you know I really right now I
was never really suspicious or you know
she cuz you know she had signed off on
them hand jobs for me so when I was on
the road she I got a headache so once
you get a hand job you always feel
better after a hand job really yeah yeah
and so you know we weren't really
complex that way very much that's all I
really didn't I don't know you didn't
ask I didn't ask
Yeah right he would you have been crazy
if she was like she hooked up once and
yours together or could you live with
that I'm not gonna live with it okay
yeah
that's a better mentality that's a much
healthier mentality the problem with it
was that she I've never talked about
this on radio but you know here Jim and
you know nothing you do is weirder than
what I've done so far right yeah
absolutely
you're like a snake [ __ ] or something
I hear you got weird video receiver you
can't keep putting this stuff in your
hair do it but you know it's uh it was a
run for a while and absolutely just
gonna say they you say like you don't
get suspicious you could live with it if
she had done something yeah yeah yeah
you know people make mistakes when she
did some things the size of things that
that were just designed to make me look
bad like she was homeless or all that
you know that I've left her with no
money and all these things are not true
and if you wanted to look me look bad
you really don't have to go past the
truth you know right a philandering
[ __ ] but you think that there's no
exaggeration necessary to show that
you're not a partner is it tough when
you've got a relationship that you're
leaving where you do have kind of
freedom to do what it is that you need
to do to then find another relationship
where somebody's going to be equally as
allowing ya you know equally is allowing
yeah well I want a sentence dude very
good yeah you know Alison is uh the girl
I'm seeing now and she's a it's just
spine surgeon and so yeah real real busy
and you know can't really you know if
she travels some she doesn't work every
day but she's gonna tries to keep up
with me but it's and then she's also a
you know big-time athlete she's almost
as old as me and but she's she was
100-meter hurdle or for the Canadian
national team and she was young still
stays in ridiculous shape right so you
don't like people that aren't busy I
don't you know I don't know I don't know
when to be around sometimes I get
annoyed when people are too busy to hang
with me yeah we do you want to bring
something on the road like a real cool
City can you come and they're like no I
gotta work and you want to go your [ __ ]
job Jim I'm making my job come with me
correct yeah yeah yeah
we can't do that because she's a surgeon
and she makes a lot of money so but you
know you take what you get so nobody
asked you to you said all right I've
read I don't know if it's sure nothing
you didn't say this was it true you did
not want to get married without a prenup
which i think is an extremely smart way
to not only did I say that I didn't get
married without a prenup so and we're
going to you know - we're gonna plan
this big huge wedding in Dallas that
that I don't know if she spent a quarter
of a million dollars on if she's been a
nickel of it and I was pissed then still
pissed about that wedding I know but I
see the way she got me to agreed to it
she said well I'll sign a prenup so yeah
I'll just you know recognize all the
things that have happened before I got
here sure which is a bunch yeah and but
when it came down to it you know they've
stalled her lawyer and my lawyer and
then it got to where it was too close to
the date for it to be valid how close to
the day I heard with him he should be a
month out yeah I think it a couple of
weeks but this got to within six or
seven days and then it was gonna be
completely void because then she signed
under duress so I thought well I don't
you know I thought I would marry her
you know because she said well then
we'll just you know we'll have this
ceremony thing it's a party people came
from all over the world and all over the
world she toured Europe said a lot over
there so so I genuinely thought I would
marry her at that time now you know I've
deeply in love with her and so but we
just never did it I mean she never the
bit was always there to sign and her
lawyer approved it my lawyer approved it
she just never did it and it turns out
in in California that matters because I
just assumed you know I'm screwed here
but it turns out I probably have anyway
but but you but there is no common law
in in California so you can live without
somebody a hundred years and if you
don't have a contract with them then if
you do you're done but if you don't
doesn't matter you're not married to him
it's huh and the same in Georgia but not
Texas so what she's claiming is that we
spent so much time in Texas visiting our
fan
performing that makes us married in
Texas that okay so the prenup was there
and basically that stalling about a
lawyer was probably to get it in that
red zone so it could be challenged later
well they signed a week before the
wedding she was under duress and they a
lot of times will get flipped that's
just one can't imagine that he wouldn't
know that yeah if I know it and I
dropped out of high school he knows and
the lawyers you know it's because you
have to provide the lawyer for her you
have to have someone look at it let her
let her have a legal person look at it
otherwise were you resentful of her
coming back and we know I want this and
do I want that or did you go in on to
part of the process no I was I was
annoyed that was annoyed by it but it is
part of the process you know it's she
still felt scorned and and for whatever
reason and at the fact I think she's
playing the the cutting room in New York
this weekend go see her she's amazing
and now Iran by the way is playing
tomorrow night at the Beacon Theater on
it was just one of the funniest guys in
the world yeah and I he's gonna be in
Hershey and in Washington DC all big
theaters you can go to Ron underscore
white on Twitter or tater salad ta te
our salad calm for Ron's dates yeah
that's really interesting what goes on
in I'm not married I've thought about it
but I'm like I would absolutely have a
prenup I would have to oh your you know
big successful guy so yeah you should
mean something if you don't you know I
made the mistake right before when I
first started seeing her she was deposed
in my divorce to a woman I really did
marry you know I was married for three
and a half years no kids and she walked
away with four and a quarter million in
cash and prizes Wow and three and a half
years we're gonna have years what state
Georgia but I married her and and you
know at that point relationship I'm like
oh there's no way she would do this this
she would never attack him and just you
know she understands that I already made
this but you know and the first time she
ever saw me I wasn't rich sure but I was
on stage at the Fox we blue-collar guys
so it was you know she had nothing to do
with it we just happened to wind in that
period of time that I was with her but
it's amazing like a lawyer gets in
someone's head and they're resentful
once you get some an angry partner or
even a [ __ ] your [ __ ] even a
mother-in-law not like the in-laws the
family starts coming in and going like
now
he shouldn't be ZZ shouldn't be treating
you like your you deserve every dime of
it yeah he wouldn't gotten there I know
it was already set up but he wouldn't
have gotten there without your support
right well I basically I offered her
every dime I'll make next year and she
said no wait this is the one now yeah
every time I'd [ __ ] I would eat Ron's
ass for every time he made next year
yeah yeah I'm not gonna do Ron White
unless she doesn't follow Ron's career
makes a tremendous amount of money
because great gigs you do [ __ ]
nothing but theatres why did she so
noted that this wasn't enough Wow Ron
once you know she wants money again it's
always that's the lawyer the lawyer the
two lawyers are closer to each other oh
yeah they're clients absolutely
during the last divorce I was you know
the answer do you have bet you hate your
wife's divorce lawyer I hate mine I
don't I told my Lulu divorce lawyer at
the divorce hearings I said if your kids
are gonna grow home grow up to be
divorce lawyers you should go home right
now
take him upstairs fill up the bathtub
and [ __ ] drown and make the world a
better place to be when two less divorce
lawyer complaints to you your lawyer
will complain boy her lawyers being a
prick meanwhile he loves that guy cuz
he's keeping it going and that guy loves
him oh geez well she my divorce lawyer
did the last marriage she admired this
guy because he [ __ ] so many people out
of money and and she openly admired him
he'd written a couple of books he died
the other day I left so soon as I found
that he died I called his office I said
I'd like to speak to John Mayhew please
[Laughter]
well I'm sorry to tell you but mr.
Mayhew passed away and I said oh okay
and I call her a bag is it I'd like to
speak to John and maybe you please
because I just told you mr. Mayhew
passed away I'm like I know I just like
hearing you saying
how long were you in the relationship
for it this last one I you know eight or
I don't know where the lines were you
know she lived apart she had her
Department the whole time we lived
together it was a back end for who's one
of those things where you're dating and
then you just kind of casual and then
you're dating and she's got her own
place you're not exactly sure where it
begins and went edition but eventually
you know we live together as a couple in
Southern California which is for how
long
seven years is the fact that there was
no contract but the contract was
approved by both does that mean that she
was ready to sign it um is that in your
favor
it's in my favor but because she has
notes on it of what she wants to change
and on one copy other side of them I
don't okay it should be no case at all
but the way it is now you know you can
still sue me and and their whole goal is
to rash she asked for eighty one
thousand a month spousal support that's
fair nine hundred and sixty thousand
dollars a year whatever that's fair yeah
yeah yes that sounded good to me yeah I
was like I'll take it you go do the work
I'll just skim off the top of it the the
profits and live like a you know so but
they just wanted me to say here's a
whole bunch of money right because we're
coming after you and I'm a vote
eighty-one thousand a month for how long
I've never heard could be yeah I would
have been all over it if it have been a
year I had had done it but they asked
for too much hoping you'll just settle
and say I grow away yeah just go away
cuz at least you won't have to pay for
her lawyer oh that's right you probably
will yeah well you'll have to pay for
her imagine although you're not married
maybe not writing a monthly check for
eighty one thousand dollars just like
there you go there you go just for the
foreseeable when I was a club head
ladder that's that was a year's pay
right and that's a hard-working guys pay
for you know doing funny bones and stuff
and so yeah it was a little a little
difficult I think ultimately you know
that we'll get past it because you know
her brother is my partner in the tequila
company and see stuff a relationship
with her family with her family who I've
known for 30 years and you like them I
do
does it complicate things over there
brain oh of course
because I mean there's you know they're
you know very very close and so anybody
also you can have been the first time I
ever walked into a comedy club and went
straight to the bar and ordered a beer
and a shot of tequila and he handed it
to me
so he was the bartender in the club I
started it see if a real history with
this guy you can't just record long
years well and then we're partners in
this tequila company so we're and and
then you know a buddy we totally totally
have gotten past it and he's kind of
help mediate and you know it's still got
to be mediated I want it I want it do
something fair but I want it to be fair
to me all sure there's a possibility to
reach her as opposed to other people who
get divorced where it's two people like
almost like you know at like North and
South Korea with just nothing but
lawyers in between them you you might
have a bridge where there's some human
contact yeah that's good that's yeah and
that's what I want you know it's when I
heard she was working the cutting room I
was my first response to it was oh I can
help oh yes she's suing me I guess I
can't really muster up a lot of hate and
hold on to it you know what then that's
good you know yeah especially if you
moved on and how did you meet the person
you're with now to meet the surgeon I
was playing golf with her and her
husband make any sense to me
and she's pretty
510 be grace a butyl short plump bald
dude and I'm like well maybe he look
great you know back in the day and but
it just you know it would then she and I
really enjoyed each other's company and
she's a really good golfer and he's
horrible
and so we know I'm gonna be up here on
Wednesday and and so you know without
telling anybody else so she and I start
playing a little more golf a little more
golfing and one day I've found a code
for the bathroom door and you know sure
what a nightmare for the husband awesome
I now have a guy with his own tour bus
oh no yeah and then he and then you go
and you play go and you realize he's a
better golfer than me too right
did you make a laugh yeah yeah and she
makes me laugh too and not a lot of
women dead recently have been shown me
laugh but she couldn't haven't Arab Lee
hae in this relationship she was and
they're in her and her husband are
really really good friends to this day
so you know they he didn't sue her for
alimony which he could have and she's
also an inventor she would invented this
unbelievable idea so and it's a so she
has these assets and things so she's not
you know she she's not looking at me for
a ride she's got her own thing yeah and
she's happy to be with you and she's got
her own her own way out which she
doesn't need you she's got her own life
oh absolutely
are you a good boyfriend I'm kind of a
shitty boyfriend are you good at it when
you're when you're in a relationship
you've been a good boyfriend Jeff at
times I have I I think I'm a look with
you if you get me you get hair teeth
dick and money
[Laughter]
they're also downside because I'm moody
and you know my I was ready to I was
ready to come up hard at the seams on
the way over here I hate the hotel they
put me in it's awful it's the littlest
hotel room I've ever seen and it's like
a joke and I smuggled my dog and so the
kind of dog is a it's a four month old
french bulldog puppy Oh Oh God yes he's
got to be adorable eat up with cute yeah
eat up where is it I don't even know the
name of the hotel I left this morning
nobody told me it was gonna be a
half-hour to get over here and there's
nowhere near the beacon but it's where
the party is for the Comedy Festival
tonight so whatever is that party
tonight yeah alright we are performing
for the Comedy Festival are you funny
Saturday night I am yeah but you weren't
invited today yeah let me go ahead and
extend the invitation
I'd love to Ronnie this is my date I
would love to you please I would love to
I'll claim marriage and try to [ __ ]
get a few dollars out of here
I got one white back so I see your make
sure you get photos taken to the to
weigh together hair teeth dick and money
hair sees dick and money but the
moodiness I get like all of a sudden
like you know from Dino holidays for
years you're doing gigs you're making
[ __ ] money you're opening your middling
500 for the week or 300 for the week and
travel and then you start making real
money and you appreciate it and you're
like oh god I'm like I'm a [ __ ] I want a
hotel room with feather pillows you
start having these things that you
require yeah well I don't I need
something bigger than a you know it
literally it's if it's 200 square feet
I'm shocked yeah it's just the tiniest
thing but once you get in it and get in
the bed and the way the TV's laid out
very very very comfortable but it's just
a little storage facility and you really
can't explain to Millennials why things
are a bad idea because they'll just roll
their eyes and yeah what about that idea
so they'll feel like they're being
attacked like why thank you yeah nobody
but why is it why everyone Tori in this
room is not socialism are you man years
are you a tit man I did this thing I
went to I was playing this new casino in
Tulsa and I just played Southern Hills
which is a beast of a golf course it was
hot so I come back and I'm I'm and also
I need to pee very important I needed to
pee on the 16th hole but it's not that
kind of golf course that you'll just
pull your shirt don't start peeing so so
they take this back we get caught in
traffic I need to pee and I want a
massage and when they take us into the
building the massage things right there
so I just stated let me to ask him I
said I need a massage and my back's
killing me and she goes we have one in
eight minutes and that's the only one
available all day and I'm like uh or do
you have a shower here because I was
really stinky and yeah we got a shower
and so but she couldn't go in there and
then she goes well there's a there was a
big water leak and there's a
construction crew in there and I'm like
I don't care I just need to pee you know
and get my shower and get massage so I
go in there and the world construction
crew is right by the toilets so I go
around in my find my locker take all my
clothes off put on my robe put on my
shoes and go over and find the showers
and there's a little day a little place
of undress and then another little
curtain and you go into your shower so I
take my clothes back off and go in there
and there's a computer screen and I'm
like no
oh what a computer screen no knobs no
nothing just a computer screen and and I
can't really see it and I push the
screen and it kind of lights up and I
push it nothing happens nothing happens
I'm like damn so I put back my robe on
put my shoes back on well back over to
my locker get my [ __ ] reading glasses
and walk back over there in there and
then you know now I can see it you know
and and and and after I did all that
[ __ ] you could change the lighting in it
and I'm like what do you think I'm gonna
do in here I dragged off in the dark
I don't need lighting I don't but it in
the night they like he goes well how was
it know this little young millennial
girl and I said well here's what you
ought to do you gotta have a knob
whither that you turn and maybe a thing
that says probably right around here you
know and then I want you know what I
want I want a shampoo bottle that says
[ __ ] shampoo biggest print on it only
print on it I don't even care what tank
and it is I can't afford say this be
sure to take your reading glasses to the
shower with you because you're gonna
need them they didn't even do that did
you figure the shower out yeah I figured
it out I just couldn't but I but I had
to go back and you know and while I was
trying to figure it out to begin with I
wasn't gonna just pee without the shower
running so I'm cooking bacon you know
how was your showers the massage resort
massage crap your crap all right now are
you a guy when you're getting a massage
who will push the hips back a little bit
just kind of hoping a finger kind of
brushes the back absolutely
[Laughter]
the resort's never resorts are tough
those are tough have you ever tried that
you I have not in a long time believe it
or not but they're in a resort it's a
very tough place yeah
yeah they tend to dress like [ __ ] ER
surgeons they have on the scrubs and you
know they're never hot and they touch
you clinically clinically yeah you can
you kind of tell like when the massage
starts yes if they're touching you a
certain way how they gonna happen yeah
you know they'll get a linger finger you
were brushing you know they'll give you
a little clue yeah yeah you're spotting
a lot of times to a clue but when they
wrap you and they like lift up and they
like they mummy wrap your legs you like
for you
yeah that's not gonna happen he doesn't
want to see my ugly dick and balls at
all wants no part of my different
absolutely does not so when you golf are
you are you always like out with other
people will you just go by yourself well
Mac we play on the road so my crew plays
and you know we usually yeah I'll take
the bus and I wake up at a golf course
like I was FedExed crawl out you bought
your own bus or do you just lease it no
I bought it
you did buy years ago I had it built but
the guy that drives it my bus driver
built it that's that's a lot of overhead
I mean the bus the the upkeep the paying
this guy and the insurance is still
cheaper than flying first-class
everywhere and and and in getting hotel
oh god no no it's not no no it's not I
have a plane too so that's mine
that's helpful and that yeah takes the
sting out of travel so my overhead is
ridiculously high so I have to do work a
lot to have to make it all happen but I
really looked at it as two separate jobs
one of them you make more money the
other one you have a life worth living
because you can't number one you can't
hit all the markets that I hit without a
bus and a plane almost I mean I was
doing 140 cities a year a few years back
how many this year I have 110 okay so to
do that so the amount diplomat a plane
cost you're doing probably an extra 30
cities because you can get to the gig
and you can be performed yeah and and
you also get a jet yeah that's nice so
that was that was I think that was the
tipping factor how big is your plane
I've heard all difference I've only gone
one time playing my 11 passengers in a
bathroom bathroom to the back right in
the gray and you can you put a seat over
the toilet the one I was in
you can we never have but it's actually
I will I really discourage people from
going to the bathroom with my plane
because it just goes into a thing that
somebody's got to take out of there so
it's full of blankets and pillows and
golf clubs and stuff oh the toilet yeah
so you can't piss on your dish you can
if it's a real you know emergency oh
there's the plane right there on this
thing oh wow that's a nice but I would
need to piss a lot when you're flying
across country will you take your plane
will you fly commercial just more
comfortable if I'm moving the plane
somewhere I'll take the plane but it's
way more comfortable
flat first class cross country then it
on a plane yes because there was nice
and I did it one time we did oddball
there's like seven comedians going for
gonna ask his plane was it you know it
was because I was with Amy and the Z's
and they got they flew they were the two
I like the headliner in the co-headliner
for oddball a few years ago so I just
went up and I think coming home was with
all of us and big Jay oakerson but
there's a shitload of us up whatnot but
you took a tiny little plane there's
that one little room in the back to piss
but I'm like I wouldn't like this
cross-country I like this for
convenience and the idea of it yeah but
you know if you get in a giant [ __ ]
lay flat seat yeah right no that's way
better way way but this to have your own
plane how much does a plane cost a plane
of that size which is not the biggest
you can get is that more than five
million dollars well knew it would be
more than ten but the but I bought it
it's my feeling is very is is old its
built in Israel in 1980
it's a west wind ones what it's called
and and right now the plane itself has
almost no value at all even though it's
a perfect plane at the age in the amount
of miles and financing you know so some
of somebody's walking around with that
much cash in their pocket sure and it's
also not for sale so that so it really
doesn't matter but so if you do
something like that sorry Ryan would you
have used it because there's an older
plane you put a lot of the money prize
just goes into the maintenance and the
upkeep and making sure the parts work
yeah yeah I paid I paid for I think it
was a million six when I bought it
okay really inexpensive for that kind of
it's not crazy for your own [ __ ]
plane that's not that's not a credits
the maintenance in the you know and the
pilots time it was costing seven
thousand dollars to fill it up with gas
but it goes coast to coast so it's a
long-range plane with big cargo halls
and and it was really preferred by drug
smugglers that's great because it would
just go so far to hold so much and
that's the Bobby Seale as named Bobby
Seale who's the guy that was uh that Tom
Cruise just played in the [ __ ] movie
oh yeah no I don't remember his name but
I know exactly yeah Maceo Barry seal
very seal yeah that's the type of stuff
they would they would probably go from
Columbia to the states with you never
wanted to put your name or your face or
anything like that on the plane it says
tater air and these gold letters on the
side and it's got a that's not it it's
above that it's the that
the there that's it so it's got a pirate
ship on the back I knew thanks jobs got
a skull and crossbones on the bottom of
it and I told my wife at the time as I
said I'm gonna put a skull and
crossbones on the bottom of the plane
and she goes you shouldn't do that and I
said why not she goes that's like saying
[ __ ] the universe I said well you're
gonna hate my other idea which was to
write [ __ ] the universe so you are the
first time you are you I do you have you
had any like moments in the plane were
you like I'll [ __ ] were there there's a
little trench in trouble or something we
got in a really bad storm one time and
and we got hit by lightning about 25
times and it lit up the wings of the
plane and we were somewhere we shouldn't
have been and me and my road manager at
the time Steve cook we're on it and
there's just us in the back going this
is good you know and it shorted some
stuff out but the planes pretty much
designed I guess to get hit by lightning
yeah plaintiff you playing a hip I had a
lot right I guess I don't know but I've
never seen it happen it's for easy and
it was just not so obviously hitting us
over and over and over I'm like I wonder
how long we can take lightning is never
supposed to strike twice we don't know
you'd expect it you're a hunk of metal
in the clouds something's gonna happen
top let's go you're gonna attract some
attention up there what the pilots say
like we could do one good thing is you
have access to the pilot you can just go
hey what's going out there frankly so
did you ask them and they're like it's
normal we're fine with a nervous so they
was just like whatever I don't know we
were smoking weed and drinking we were
chasing the buzz take the sting out of
it how long was it bad uh I don't even
know maybe probably 40 minutes or
something a long 40 though yeah well it
was it was edgy really edgy and that's
out of that you know the these planes
are so overpowered for what they do so
they don't crash you know really
literally you haven't heard of a private
jet going down since Payne Stewart died
and that was McCann me that was operator
error what happened with that beacon I
think the cabin pressure they lost they
all basically froze to death or or the
cabin pressure they just they just kind
of sat there they were frozen the plane
just kept going either shot the plane
down or they just let out
gasps and loaded somewhere up around
Michigan okay dad but what happened was
he put these fish he was taking them
that he caught and he they're packed and
dries and you and you can't be confined
with dry eyes and and that's what that's
what put him to sleep
there's no what happened and then they
just slept till they ran out of gas and
Wow I heard they were all also the dry
ice put everyone on the plane to sleep
in freezing because but but yeah it
wasn't a plane issue no so they weren't
frozen on the plane for some reason I
thought they said they because they had
a plane flying next to the windows were
fog why were they I don't know the exact
answer to any of these questions but
Diane that's oh they were merely
speculative that might not even be true
okay no but I heard that they were all
asleep so they didn't suffer they just
[ __ ] no not at all there's like they
just kind of past that how cool is the
first time you got in your own [ __ ]
plane that's gotta be pretty amazing you
know it I used to use it so so much that
I would always have the plane the bus
pull up to the airport and I'd land a
plane you know and I was big showy stuff
and then but a lot you know I liked it I
never I never sat around envision any of
this kind of [ __ ] happening sure so even
when it happened to Foxworthy I didn't
even it's been one second going well I'm
probably gonna be a huge comic someday
you know I like to be in a club
headliner and then we did some stuff
like that but I really never sat around
thinking about this is what I'm driven
to do I want to be a successful rich you
know comic and in it and it ended but it
happened anyway and so you know and it
end it's been going on for quite a while
I mean I'm 31 years in the business and
which is a pretty good stint and and
then you know in that and then the in
theaters for 15 years and Ron is the guy
that the comedians talking about like of
all the guy everyone knows Foxworthy and
invol and Lara and Larry of course
you're the guy though because that's
like he bought a [ __ ] bus like to
come that's what people were talking
about was with some comedian the [ __ ]
wrong way bought a bus like no one could
believe you bought the bus like that so
that's like rockstars way to live yeah
well I'd you know I knew I wanted it
it's cuz it was cuz they were charging
17,000
to Wrentham and plus your driver and 350
bucks a day plus you know costs a dollar
a mile to move it and so you know I just
started looking and found a guy that was
really good at it and they built it for
me and he still I was the bus company
but he just runs the road with me
playing golf
what did you want on it that normally
wouldn't have come on a bus like that I
I had a kind of a minimalist approach to
it cuz I saw all these buses that were
two million dollars and that had you
know all I mean it's all kinds of things
I knew I would never use like any kind
of stove at all so you so my bus was
pretty like more of a like closer to
like 850 okay even Larry
Larry's buses two and a half million
Larry owns a bus - oh I didn't know that
yeah so what does his bus have the years
doesn't 50 televisions and and in a
pull-out BBQ grill that swings out of
the bag it's really and it's nice I mean
I was jealous it's a quadruple slide-out
so it gets huge it's got a huge TV that
drops down from the ceiling and so it's
beautiful if million-dollar bus I was a
little jealous and then I was like but
and oddly enough I don't have to
footitis so when I see a really really
nice plane I don't wish it was mine
because I know what it cost to operate
what it costs to buy what it cost to put
pilots on it and so I love my plane
specifically because it was a good
choice what's to footitis that's what if
your boat you know you have a boat and
you just see another boat two-foot
longer and your boat no good anymore oh
you wish you had that's a great thing to
not have because right around people who
have planes and but enjoy somebody oh
yeah I'm nobody I'm guarantee I'm the
poorest guy in my neighborhood and
people squander bigger fortunes than
mine every goddamn day and and so I you
know I really don't have this illusion
that things could have been a little
better or should have been that better
but you know I'm so alive damn lucky
it's just ridiculous I was building
builds the guy knows I I don't know Jeff
I've met Jeff once I don't know him I
think he came in once an Opie and
Anthony Romano before like a five-minute
thing is thankful still touring
yeah yeah yeah bill still does does some
dates and Jeff does too
I don't know what Dan's up to these days
but they all they all work you know and
I met up math too but he would Larry the
to the two guys that are mostly on the
road that enjoy the writing it's mostly
me I don't think he's really doing that
much I don't know that but I really
finalists a commercials whatever he's
got his things
yeah I can't even imagine what a perfect
fit prilosec and Larry the case and it
was genius it really was and you know
and they listened to him you know that
fan base is is your huge deal they love
you too though yeah there's a difference
in the fan base because we did a couple
of shows together that was called the
no-collar comedy tour or something after
Blue Kyle sure we're gonna try to do and
it worked hugely and and I would close
some of them and he would close some of
them but the ones I closed the faint his
super fans they come dressed like him
and all that stuff soon as I got on
stage they would just really wow he was
hard to follow in an arena yeah I mean
it just did his his fans were so in love
with him I mean it's just this
unexplainable but not unexplainable he's
really good paced rhythm and time in
comic and they love her but I mean but
my fans don't hate him I mean these guys
were just flat offended when he left the
stage and they saw I got to where I was
like listen you close them all I don't
care
yeah and and you know that I don't have
to look at the powders down absolutely I
did the same thing when I co-headline
with Dave Attell we split the money
we're supposed to flip-flop and when he
was late for Boston one time you've
never seen anyone jump on stage faster
one time well Dave you're late